i completely agree i love greta i think
what she's done is incredible but i
think there's also more systemic issue
which is you know i heard a few times at
this conference barack obama's sentence
of i have hope blah blah blah into the
youth
all of those empty statements are
completely pointless i have hope seeing
people my age going into the streets and
fighting to be elected fighting to
change the system but the issue is
they're not being let in
so you have barriers to entry in most
existing democracies in the u.s since we
talked a lot about the us you have to be
35 to run for president in italy you
have to be 65 to be president and 25 to
vote for being a senator
how is this
asking us to represent the hope of
future generations we are the future
we need to be let in the room which
means concretely you know talking about
hope and so on my hope is that the older
generation gets out
and leaves the room for me
but i'm actually very serious i'm not
just being provocative i'm very serious
there's no gaining power and there's no
change in the system without having the
power and it is too easy to consistently
look at us and tell us oh but you will
make such a great world you guys have
such strong values it's beautiful you
protest
we do and we want the power to be able
to change the system create justice and
create hope i don't think this is right
also like to say that you want to get
rid of all the old jesus it's an
exaggeration i don't want to get rid of
i want the barriers to entry
[Applause]
that was the club for saying that we
need youthful minds
okay robert and then jeff flake
well uh
i i think that we were talking earlier
about democracy and i think that
democracy needs constantly to be
reinvented
because the world changes and we need to
and we need to move on in all kinds of
ways like for example
you know what i don't think democracy is
a term that is so
you know abused
because i don't know it's like really
what does democracy mean because it's
happening
i can tell you in myanmar there are
people who are dying
uh to try and preserve
a very mediocre flawed democracy against
the military who took over nine months
ago except that they haven't succeeded
and people are dying for this so it does
mean something but it can be made better
constantly um
well everybody i didn't win many much
support when i mentioned at dinner last
night that maybe six-year-olds should be
given the vote
well actually because
if
if you
did give them the vote they would take
it very seriously more serious children
get very serious about these things if
you tell them they're actually going to
have a say in running the country
if you don't like six-year-old then
maybe we could negotiate a compromise
and start at nine years old but
but uh they're the future so if you want
to change the way in which governments
run give the vote to the people who who
whose future it's going to be um why 18
um uh
uh because and then people say no well
they'll just vote the way their parents
tell them but you show me any child that
does what their parents tell them
so why not why not think a little bit
more radically um
we had a child for a president for four
years
no he wasn't a child he was a mean child
he was a child
i have a six-year-old grandson i like
him but i'm not about to give him the
vote
the chance to pick anything but his
halloween costume or something like that
i i i do i mean as a former politician i
certainly on issues that i've held dear
to my heart immigration reform
uh be more welcoming of refugees for
example those i always looked at as a
republican
for
the youth because they were far more
supportive i think youth in general
have fewer biases
are
are less tribal
and so there's great hope coming up
gratefully
and that's this hope that we're speaking
of i think it does lie
in our youth but let's face it if we
want to move quickly
on climate change
unless the youth
have a way to figure out
how to price carbon
it's going to rely on people our age and
people who are in power no it is it is
the youth supports reports that have
been done supports the scientific
community and it has been widely showed
through fridays for future and so on
there are many many solutions that exist
on how to price carbon and i completely
agree with you on this policy but that's
what i'm saying but if they're not in a
position and you can't put them in
charge and say all right we're going to
give you the reigns to exxon continue to
put them in charge i'm asking you to
lower the barriers so that they can take
charge themselves and change the system
themselves the issue is that there are
too many barriers to entry systematic
biases not enough funding and so on for
the youth to get into
then
make a deal on 12.
um
in america you have to be 25 to run for
congress 35 first 30 to run for the
senate 35 for president uh it seems
reasonably you'd be pretty young to be a
35 year old president but i i'm simply
saying there's great hope
and and and i rely on that and uh i
favor the youth vote
i did better with the youth than i did
among people uh older than me
but
if we're wanting action now things we
can't say all right we're going to put
the youth in charge we need to look at
the power structure that's there and
actually form policies that will be good
and in climate change it's desperately
needed we need to move forward
but i don't think we can wait